[Applause]
[Music]
guys I have something to tell you
I've been lying to you I don't actually
need lies now I'm kidding I did this
when I said floor gank for life I wasn't
telling true today it's the last day of
flora game my tambourine is packed up I
can't even use this I'm going back to my
old set up with comfortable chair
no more floor gang this is so sad
I want to see the chat only with apps
and no other comments it hurts but to
share ourself up one last floor gang no
pillows just me the floor I would
suppose stubby and good ol low I imagine
sympathy [ __ ] courage Chris that Felix
Kjellberg guy what up in loser goddamn
hey no more microphone setup as a damn
it it's literally it's hanging off the
wall by the way this can't even see it I
use a towel to not scratch the wall and
it's hanging on this coat rack just so
we're clear what I'm being working with
here okay oh god did you see my pillow I
mean no more pillow it's just me the
floor let's do this
alright you try sitting on the floor for
months see how your butt feels okay kids
learning their native language kids
learning to language just because their
parents are from different countries
Felix and Mars are killing Swedish it's
hollien German he said I was always so
jealous at kids in school that I had
like a different like a French mom or
something because they would always ask
the French lessons in class without
having to work for it the video the
tuber simulator add at the end what I'm
gonna fix my camera by one day we're
making strides on this channel you'll
see you'll see I'll protect you little
one thanks Brad
god damn that 12-pack though damn that's
I'm working for you may not like it but
this is what peak physique look like
goddamn Lamar my daughter heard the
intro immediately it got out and looked
at my phone it's working
yes yes yes plan takeover Coko is
initiated step one completed Felix
Kjellberg sweetie philosopher Papa
Gloria news anchor PB PI youtuber so
that's how it works
is it to me or is Felix Kjellberg kind
of hot goddamn head guy come here come
in come in yeah look at this look at
this yeah come here we'll finish this
last video together look it's you that's
amazing huge PP - y + blue nay
they'll definitely be a meme review the
new Playstation 5
I'll keep my opinions to myself until
then but goddamn it's ugly hold on is no
one gonna acknowledge the better camera
quality I'm just calling correct thing
directly because sign doesn't want to do
it PewDiePie I do everything symmetrical
no why do you notice that stuff what's
wrong I mean I notice it - good job you
know what is it this is an age-old
episode come on I try my best to draw
Marseille an 80s anime style deafening
TT
Tambourine dead I bury him in baskets
this sad I cry small peepee bipeds this
is my response god that smoke P P P P P
P because in privacy they respond here I
hope you understand what that means
that's way harsher
yeah you better stop fine burrito
glasses you win this round big peepee
you now have normal people but you will
never know it's working stack up best
selection
come on floors sponsor me come on I'm on
your side I'm your ally I'm trying to
hell
alright wolves make wolf tracks duck
makes duck tracks oh hell yeah oh hell
yeah
you goddamn believe it those are my legs
what does it mean to be good person what
does it mean what does it mean what good
one
you forgot the you'll never play /
Berber dude I need that melon helmet
last night I had a dream where Adam oh
yeah someone posted this I had to dream
I asked Siri if I could take a photo you
said I'm wearing a watermelon helmet
it's a prophet who posted this it's a
prophet the prophecy he stole my
watermelon helmet and said it's not
bucket gang while running away whoever
posted this we need more insight come on
what's happening next hey that's awesome
we're on episode 11 now and finish and
Ferb we watched one episode every
livestream check it out become a member
thank you first comment on PewDiePie's
channel okay what is it
Lowell just Lowell that's awesome that's
so cool I think I remember that comment
is that weird I was like oh my god
someone thought it was funny
yay I bet their post more now thanks
Brandon very cool true floor gang
members don't stand up for Jenny
yeah I've never stood up in my entire
life
I don't even know how Jake Paul going to
jail for six months me who thought there
was an episode a Pew news episode I came
looking for gold
and I found copper you guys really want
peonies Bank I don't know maybe I'll
bring it back guys maybe I'll bring it
I want that helmet I need that helmet
beautiful you really captured it a
perfect example of PewDiePie fan art
right here right here
big beeping why don't you skip the ad
the ad yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
teacher
[Music]
wait what does it say there Wow nihongo
jover this name all made it through
gozaimasu thank you my Japanese is good
congratulations
it is not boilers design I know this is
an ad technically but I was really glad
to see you guys really liked this
animation do you feel really nailed it
and the animation was so good who ever
animated I don't know I wanted it to be
a neon genesis evangelion reference but
then they drew me as like the main
character which is the biggest beta of
all times I'm like just alright do Neon
Genesis Evangelion but draw me as Jojo
character and it turned that's so good
so good big beefy they're available in
us right now hopefully we can distribute
them elsewhere in the future they are so
good
I've been holding myself we're not
drinking more than one a day cuz goddamn
they are so good I know I'm biased
because it's mine but legit it's so good
check it out link in description when
the anime character is way too cocky and
makes that smile come on that's not even
a good smile you know it's gonna be a
good movie when that's right all my boob
is good such a good intro I can't even
do it again I did so perfectly yeah
that's how big it's gonna be one day one
day Tamborine OPP will be so large it
will pierce the moon and all the
ceilings the prophecy has spoken
Wow beautiful keep sending in your
animations please it's clearly working
we need more those three Kitty sections
have been kids who thought it was Coco
damn you get it cos kids dislike Coco
Bell and Gotham when aquatic life
watches pee deep I work at the review oh
god what's gonna happen to my muscles
after floor gang no twenty percent no
hey through my Mayan Edgar infinite
superb cell agent m and agent e
beautiful
just for the record and my is probably
the height of Perry but still very big
PP cuz epic damn Oh wicked Smith that's
amazing you know what sloth told me I
can now give out Felix chosen golden PP
though damn the hell this is the future
tambourine oh there it is hey you get
the Felix chosen the word that's amazing
well deserved rag bag a egg change name
Jesus Christ I'm joking
my friend made this pretty fight theme
keyboard for me what do you think yeah
it looks cool little Gator but I like it
nice that's so nice
twenty four days until smell
birthday I guess now we know when I will
return to Minecraft voice it's happening
smash like first post one my one two six
scale hope he sees this does that mean
am twenty meters in this photo that's
awesome that's Matson why am I wearing
yaysies why is my head is that Felix
Kjellberg Rufus
I don't not just have legs I do not have
anything this is the true form of floor
gang right here very nice
youtube.com slash collecting weekly
thank you very much that's very cool big
beeping what the hell is this God God
that's what that day's beautiful voice
when they hit puberty I feel my voice
nice nice nice nice big baby little
peepee
rest in peace lovely very nice we now
have double Tam Rahim there what just
wait for triple tambourine you'll hear
it from the moon my parents when I asked
them for forgetting tier three my
parents when my little brother once Coco
melon premium and friction no guys right
now we have special offer if you get to
your free membership we have only fans
at a hundred and ten million subs I will
do leg reveal but if your floor gang
Tier three you'll get early access
through photos of my links and more if
that doesn't convince your mom to buy
floor gang membership I don't know ah
dude I need that melon helmet
we need to amass an army of melon helmet
we have the gear we just need you come
on floor gang we just need Candace to
show Mom 2020 and maybe it'll disappear
honestly not bad idea and I understand
this because I watch Phineas and Ferb
every livestream we watched one episode
very epic big peepee son mom can we have
penalization fire please son we already
have PlayStation five at home place is
your favorite oh I mean that is eerily
similarly looking I say big words thank
you
I don't get it I think it's so ugly damn
Doofenshmirtz got a girl
NoHo I didn't know don't do monetize I
didn't know I'm sorry oh I could finally
drink this on camera guys I think Peter
pie still Felix shell Brooks I can
that's right
ever since that dumbass leaked his email
I got it
pewds after he loses coke Ameland diss
track I don't know if I should do it but
if this video gets me 500 thousand likes
I'll consider it
feel exact the floor gang 20% muscle
increase Felix before floor game no no
Ricardo go what go ahead go go away go
wait alright now you get the size
reference all right you see they're
smaller she's small she tiny she caught
her Pomeranian that's why people who
look like Pierce goddamn it why there's
so many so many people trying to steal
my drip man I'm not cool with it
I'm not cool with it I built that not
just one meatball but two meatballs and
then I kept our in between and terror
yeah we haven't built that IKEA Tower
yet but we are building God in Terraria
check out member epic I'll stop chilling
for it but it's for charity
so exactly Felix in your latest Jubilee
video when you said Alexa buy me hair
gel my Alex I heard it and started
buying hair gel off of Amberson Alexa v
your hair gel okay Google buy hair gel
okay Google buy hair gel
Alexa by hair gel 500 hair gel no Google
no council now we have double tambourine
my chords roof low tambourine I ordered
a bunch of tambourines up the dark web
forbidden tambourine I'm that desperate
to beat cocoa melon okay
that one looks epic I like this hey
that's cool
if cocoa melon mom and dad are both
brunette then why is cocoa melon baby
blood oh my god expose expose no my G
fuel no dammit
Ricardo what did you do what
okay now I like the PlayStation 5 okay
now with gently all right I'm gonna end
that episode there thank you for
becoming members thank you for
subscribing leg reveal and 110 million
see you guys next time for the last time
floor gang oh god my jet fuel again oh
damn it
keep knocking it over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
exclusively at gmail.com